es ist ja aktuell viel vom heißen herbst
die rede und zwei parteien bei dem
parlament die versuchen den protest
anzuheizen die einer ganz links und die
andere ganz rechts dieses land braucht
einen heißen herbst und die
bundesregierung weiß dass es ein heißer
herbst wird dass die bürger sich zur
wehr setzen dass sie auf die straße
gehen wie hoch ist das
eskalationspotenzial vereinen sich linke
und rechte also möglicherweise in einem
wut herbst wie das sachsen anhalts
ministerpräsident befürchtet sondern
sind die rechten und die linken auf der
gleichen straße zum gleichen thema ich
habe ein paar ganz aktuelle politische
insights für euch die einschätzung der
sicherheitsbehörden was linke sagen was
rechte sagen und wie groß das
protestpotenzial ist
mein name ist andrea maurer ich bin
politische korrespondentin im zdf
hauptstadtstudio 1 mal vorweg
friedlicher protest ist natürlich völlig
legitim demonstrieren das ist grundrecht
das versichern natürlich auch die
sicherheitsbehörden immer wieder mit
denen ich spreche laut einer umfrage von
insa im juli jedenfalls kann sich schon
jetzt jeder zweite deutsche vorstellen
gegen hohe energiepreise auf die straße
zu gehen und ihr könnt ihr euch das
vorstellen
und wenn ja auf welche demos würdet ihr
gehen wie hoch schätzt ihr die gefahr
ein dass ein heißer herbst
möglicherweise eskaliert diskutiert
gerne unten mit in den kommentaren
dass die sorgen der menschen schon jetzt
ziemlich groß und ziemlich real sind das
werden wir jedenfalls immer wieder wir
haben acht angestellte wir haben angst
wir haben angst vor dem winter wir haben
angst vor unsere energiekosten wir haben
blanke existenzangst die heizkosten usw
bewegt uns ja alle alles wird erhöht
alles teurer und für uns rentner ist es
dann auch zu überlegen wo machen wir
abstriche wir sollen jetzt ja kalt
duschen und und und gas einsparen kann
weder groß mit dem krieg zu tun das sind
bürger stimmen die wir im
brandenburgischen neuruppin gesammelt
haben als der kanzler am 17 august dort
war ihr erinnert euch er ist heftig
ausgebuht worden von etwa 300
gegendemonstranten
[Applaus]
die afg hat er zum protest aufgerufen
aber auch eine handvoll fridays for
future aktivisten waren da und plakate
der linken waren zu sehen neuruppin
haben dann viele auch als signal
genommen dass ich da links und rechts
eine protestbewegung zusammenbraut die
möglicherweise nicht mehr richtig
auseinander gehalten werden kann aber
ist das so das habe ich mal einen
protestforscher für euch gefragt es gibt
ja innerhalb gelingt wenn man das so
sagen möchte die tradition bei
akteuren auch mitzumischen die weiter
rechts die weiter rechts zu verordnen
sind das geht auf die montags mahnwachen
zurück das haben auch balkone zu testen
gesehen dass insbesondere personen aus
dem umfeld von sahra wagenknecht hier
durchaus keine berührungsängste hatten
fakt ist beide parteien wollen einen
heißen herbst die linke nennt es heißen
herbst gegen die soziale kälte die afg
ruft den leuten zu heißer herbst statt
kalte füße dass beide nun vom heißen
herbst drehen ist zumindest ein indiz
dafür dass rechte und linke um ein
protestpotenzial konkurrieren mit
gleichem kampfbegriff und ähnlichen
themen energiepreise inflation sozialer
ungleichheit und vielleicht auch mit
gleichem termin montags wenn auch die
linke hat ja jetzt zu neuen montagsdemos
in leipzig aufgerufen aktuell sind da
gerade viele querdenker auf der straße
die lage ist schon jetzt unübersichtlich
das sagt mir der sächsische
innenminister armin schuster mit dem ich
für euch und unser thema hier ein
exklusives interview geführt habe also
solange die linke so kommuniziert wie
sie es tut mit dieser wortwahl wie diese
alarmierenden sorgt sie an die selbst
dafür dass nun wirklich jeder in der
rechten ecke diese chance nutzen will
für für die sicherheitsbehörden ist das
deutlich erschwerend wenn sie jetzt bei
unseren lage
vorträgen dabei wären dann würden sie
hören wir sind dann sagen die die die
die experten wir sind nicht mehr in der
lage zu sagen dass eine cola demo oder
das ist eine ukraine es ist im prinzip
jetzt ein bisschen bei uns bei den
versammlungen das bild wir sind in einer
multiplen krisenlage kroner nicht
bewältigt
das thema ukraine energiemangel lage
eventuell kriegen wir auch noch
stärkere migrations lage dazu und in
dieser multiplen lage können sie auch in
versammlungen nicht mehr das fein
säuberlich auseinanderhalten warum sind
die menschen auf der straße
[Musik]
montags demonstrieren in ostdeutschland
das ist sagen wir mal historisch nicht
neutral es gibt das original die
friedliche revolution gegen die
vorgängerpartei der linken die sed oder
hier massenproteste gegen die hartz iv
reform 2004 mit der flüchtlingskrise
2015 dann demos gegen zuwanderung päda
und co und aktuell die querdenken demos
während der pandemie der ostbeauftragte
der linken sören paul man denkt nun vor
allem an neue lautstärke montagsdemos
wie damals gegen hartz 4 und träumt von
der gleichen größenordnung sich damals
gegen die hartz-iv-gesetze ging waren
mehrere zehntausend menschen auf den
straßen auch in leipzig damals über
50.000 auf einer demonstration dieses
potential halte ich für realistisch auch
wieder abzurufen es ist eine
größenordnung die wir übrigens auch vom
afg chef hören seine freude darüber dass
nun auch die linke zum montagsdemos
aufruft die kann group aller dann auch
wirklich kaum verbergen wissen sie wer
sich unseren interessen anschließt der
ist immer herzlich willkommen hier geht
es um die sache hier geht es um unsere
interessen um die deutschen interessen
unser land zuerst applaus für payment
aufruf den gab es auch ganz rechts auf
ihrem telegramm kanal feiern ihn die
freien sachsen die der verfassungsschutz
als rechtsextrem verdachtsfall einstuft
zitat wir dürfen uns nicht mehr
künstlich in verschiedene lager spalten
lassen es wird deshalb zeit dass wir
alle aufstehen und dafür gebührt sören
pellmann für seinen mutigen aufruf dank
thüringens linker ministerpräsident bodo
ramelow hat seine partei dann auch
sofort gewann vor zu großer nähe zu
rechtsextremen beim montagsdemos ramelow
sagt auch die rechten wurden zu recht
kritisiert als sie sich der symbolik der
montagsdemos bemächtigt haben bums das
war ziemlich deutlich die linke
parteispitze höre ich nun rudert zurück
es müssen ja nicht immer der montag
seien rechte und nazis und ihre symbole
sollen nicht geduldet werden ob das
gelingt wird montag der fünfte neunte
zeigen denn der steht fest hier der
flyer der auftakt wie es heißt es
zumindest für unsere region sollte am
montag sein wir sind jetzt im gespräch
mit gewerkschafterinnen und
gewerkschafter mit sozialvereinen
sozialverbänden und da ist noch einiges
im fluss und ich gehe davon aus dass wir
ein breiteres bündnis droht ihm bekommen
weil ich dann mehr über ein solches
breites bündnis wissen wollte habe ich
mal gewerkschaften und sozialverbände
angeschrieben ob sie einen gemeinsamen
aufruf mit der linken für den fünften
planen und ob der begriff heißer herbst
ein begriff ist den sie verwenden würden
der paritätische wohlfahrtsverband
schreibt mir zu allem nein der
sozialverband schreibt von unserer seite
aus ist nichts geplant anfragen gab es
auch keine vdk der sozialverband die
tafeln und der mieterbund setzen erst
mal auf einen sozialgipfel im kanzleramt
also auch politische verständigung sieht
also so aus als stünden die linke
bislang noch ohne größeres bündnis da
aber vor dem größeren problem das auch
rechte zu ihrer demo kommen könnten
massenprotest ist das noch nicht jetzt
lasst uns aber noch mal schauen wie die
sicherheitsbehörden die lage einschätzen
[Musik]
aktuell sind massenproteste nicht
absehbar das höre ich auch in
hintergrundgesprächen immer wieder die
lage könnte sich aber verschärfen sollte
es tatsächlich zu energie engpässen
kommen oder sollte sich der gaspreis
verzehnfachen was ich hier in berlin als
möglichkeit auch schon ab und an gehört
habe die regierung jedenfalls scheint
gerade noch zu schwanken ob sie
öffentlich einen heißen herbst
befürchtet oder ob sie eher vermittelt
dass sie alles tut um den sozialen
frieden zu wahren ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht auch noch das annalena
baerbock im juli volksaufstände
befürchtete und kurz danach
zurückruderte und was sagt der kanzler
auf die frage ob er mit unruhen rechnet
nein ich glaube nicht dass es in diesem
land zu unruhen in dieser skizzierte
form kommen wird ich habe das bewusst
mit diesem begriff du wirst nicht
alleine durch die zukunft geben gesagt
you never walk alone deshalb bin ich
ganz zuversichtlich die bürgern und
bürger sind glaubt sie machen sich
nichts vor sie wissen dass das jetzt
nicht ganz einfach wird auch die
sicherheitsbehörden scheinen uneins wie
deutlich die warnungen seien müssen
vielfach höhere ich bloß keinen protest
herbeireden den ball flach halten für
das gegenteil hat sich allerdings der
verfassungsschutz chef aus thüringen in
einem zdf-interview entschieden das
ziemlich für furore gesorgt hat also wir
befürchten im herbst wenn die szenarien
so eintreffen wie wir sie momentan
einschätzen eine hochemotionale
explosive und gewalttätige situation wo
es zu straßenprotesten kommen wird die
von extremisten unterwandert und
geschürt werden dagegen ist das was wir
in der korona pandemie geliebt haben
wahrscheinlich eher ein kindergeburtstag
der verfassungsschutz hat nun eine
einheit phänomen bereichsübergreifende
sonderauswertung gegründet die
rechtsextremisten linksextremisten und
verfassungsfeinde im blick haben soll
der sächsische innenminister vor dessen
haustür die montagsdemos er quasi
stattfinden der plädiert schon jetzt für
einen ressortübergreifenden krisenstab
im kanzleramt wie wir ihn aus der korona
pandemie kennen ich baue darauf vor ganz
ehrlich ich baue darauf dass wir mit
einem guten krisenmanagement der
bundesregierung
mit einer guten abgestimmt hat über die
ressourcen und die länder und dann mit
einer gezielten krisenkommunikation die
die bürger brauchen so viel vertrauen
erwecken und dann noch die entlastungs
pakete gezielt wirken dann kriegst du
nur noch die auf die straße mit denen
wir umgehen können was meint ihr wird
sich das bei protesten auseinander
halten lassen wer links und wer rechts
ist wird dieser herbst heiß oder bleibt
dass ein politischer traum von linken
und rechten und was müsste die regierung
eurer meinung nach tun damit es nicht zu
massenprotesten oder unruhen kommt ich
freue mich auf eure kommentare und
abonniert doch auch unseren zdf heute
kanal da findet ihr auch andere folgen
von inside politics meine kolleginnen
kollegen und ich ordne regelmäßig das
aktuelle politische geschehen für euch
ein